coffee on a Tuesday and blog 8 right
so Halloween was yesterday in the
weekend was a whole lot of fun my
friends had a lot of cool costumes too
and I love that you know I had friends
who put a lot of work into it cuz just
makes the holiday awesome I'm
actually gonna put these down because
it's a little bit dangerous to have
adamantium to your computer screen so
before I get to the main event of this
vlog that's when I mentioned for a
moment what I did last night for actual
Halloween I actually got the chance to
see one of my heroes last night in
concert the author Neil Gaiman at the
Ebel theater on Wilshire if you haven't
read anything by Neil Gaiman start doing
that right now if you ever get the
chance to hear him read live in concert
just buy the ticket don't even think
about it performed with his wife Amanda
Palmer of The Dresden Dolls so never was
too much into her music but to hear her
live was breathtaking
after the show they came out to sign
autographs and buy some weird turn of
luck they just started the line right
where we were standing so I got a chance
to shake Neil's hand and just extend my
thanks for everything unfortunately I
don't have any video that oh ah proof
just goes to show how many times I wear
a pair of jeans okay let's get to the
main event of this blog which my friends
do a web series of sketch comedy shorts
called the burns worth Saturday so in
honor of Halloween they did a short film
called Pete and Larry go to the haunted
hotel rented out a room at the beautiful
Langham Hotel in Pasadena and film there
for about 12 hours about a week it was
primarily my friend Stephens project and
I helped out as much as I could see
though I wanted to film some behind the
scenes footage so that I could put it on
this blog and show you what it's like to
make a film over a full day so without
any further ado here it is the making of
Pete and Larry at the haunted hotel
where we do what are you doing I want it
to be static I mean what are you doing
at punch you out I finish up my
punch to not understand in there like
this and Stephen goes oh hello Larry
I don't see how that was the door bit
looks so sloppy I really think that if
it's if we look at the same time that's
the only way it's gonna work we got a
major problem from the keynote speaker
at the Chi six conference so I suggested
they put it in a that's where are we in
the filming we're in the last scene of
the movie yeah the second set of but I
watched I watched The Dark Knight again
thinking you guys are insane because
it's just on a whole nother level even
with Heath Ledger it's just a whole
nother level of you saying that you
think we're insane to think that Batman
Begins is better than Dark Knight
absolutely
the problem is this whole scene just
keeps going action go back into the
abyss from what you
it's to making of Hornet Oh indeed
alright then you just turn your head
gear head on top of mine
so there you go that's about 12 hours of
filming condense into four minutes check
for the link of that short film when the
rest of the Saturdays in the doobly-doo
I also want to say that I'm really proud
of my friend Steven and all my friends
we're continuing to make things you know
they want to do it for a living but I
think it's important that everybody does
that everybody makes it whether it be a
comedy short a dramatic short a painting
a book a song and essay scopes you're a
dancer show what has important that no
matter who you are no matter what you do
for a living that you take some time to
make something that has no other purpose
besides itself it's important to tell
about our soul so that when people watch
the things we make or read the things we
make or listen to the things we make
they can know who we are